what's going on guys sorry for the very
late review here but so many movies come
out at the end of the year that it gets
tough to see all of them but my wife and
I just saw hidden figures and I think
you were pretty excited to this movie I
was really excited I was so happy to see
him come out about Catherine G Johnson
because I did a report on her and in
high school it was like nice yeah I mean
I got to be honest I didn't really know
that much about her or the other
characters in this movie so it was kind
of cool to learn some stuff about them
yeah it was a little more condensed
obviously at least condense some
different time pieces together into one
movie what is really accurate the most
part on I loved every minute of it
though I enjoy historical science movies
because that's what I was really into
growing up I loved science and history
and math that was my field house if you
will yeah I mean I've always had
interest in space and astronomy
so space movies no matter what the
subject I've always interested me
whether it's science fiction or it's you
know retelling true events and if you
don't know essentially what this movie
is about is mainly three women who work
at NASA and who are dealing with quite a
bit of racial prejudice due to their
skin color which is something that was
extremely common at the time but they
have the rare circumstance of being in
this incredible field and they're really
pioneers and what they're trying to do
but at the same time they're dealing
with a ton of people who aren't allowing
them to do what they need to do because
they don't have access to certain file
there's certain areas or one of the
characters in particular has to run very
far to use the restroom because they
have specific restrooms for them and so
it makes everything difficult and it's
really about how these characters
navigate NASA while also creating
different math formulas and things that
just didn't exist at the time to help
people get into space Kathryn was
basically creating an entire new field
of science with her group for aerospace
engineering it's not something to have
it's been really done at that point so
they were trying to create a new formula
but they realized they didn't really
need to create a new formula they needed
to use an old formula to balance out the
new stuff that they were doing which
makes a lot of sense because math is
always math you can't really change
numbers
right so I appreciate that because I
love science and math I was watching on
for those on the board go by and like I
recognize all those thank-you bills in
college oh yeah I was like I'm dumb I
don't know those me I appreciate it as I
was following along like oh so much math
I'm so happy right now the performances
in this movie across the board are all
fantastic Octavia Spencer is amazing
taraji P Henson's very good janelle
monae kevin costner shows up who I
completely forgot was in this movie so I
thought the further 100k Kevin Kloster
your your boy Jim Parsons is in the
movie from Big Bang Theory I know you
his excited to him he's kind of a dick
in the movie though he's a bit of a dick
yeah it wasn't the greatest character um
it was cool that was nothing I like but
it's movie because it doesn't
necessarily beat you over the head with
the like you know the one-up scenes or
someone's like I got you good you know
you stupid person like it has a few
scenes like that where you really want
to see some characters get what's coming
to them but it doesn't get too overly
sentimental it doesn't get to like you
know unrealistic there it's a it's a
feel-good movie oh yeah it definitely is
a feel-good movie it's one of those
movies where it's like it's just
somebody trying to accomplish their
goals and they're ignoring everything
else around them and just utilizing the
brains that they have in a room to
accomplish their goals which is putting
somebody into space Kevin Costner one
point says everybody nasa peas the same
color right it's cool to watch people
who have a specific mindset of how they
view everyone have to work around that
racial prejudice to get the job done you
start to see the people clearly who are
prejudiced and who are not really
prejudiced and those who just don't care
because they just they don't even notice
somebody's of a different color than
then they just don't care it's not
they're not focus on that there's a
great thing in the movie that I don't
want to spoil because it's really good
and for the best games in the movie
where a character kind of has finally
had enough and she's just like look this
needs to stop yeah I really wasn't a
teen idol I love this movie it was so
good yeah Keane was long gone the
directing was well done all the shops
were nice everything was smooth it
flowed really well and then we both
liked the title too because it's hidden
years about the maths and what's hidden
you know that that needs one person to
find that so they get the problem solved
there's also these three important
figures of women who are kind of back
behind the limelight who are now getting
pushed forward to the forefront right
because these are not characters really
anybody we know about in history unless
you went looking the only reason I
really found out about her is because of
this project and I was trying to find a
female scientist to use for this project
because it was just about picky
scientists it was didn't specify what
parameters for a scientist it just had
to be scientist out of my entire class
of 30 there were two of us who actually
did a female scientist and that's
stubborn when you really think about it
because there are so many female
scientists and they just don't ever get
any attention whatsoever everyone always
talks about the guy who went into space
and then which is obviously important
but that's where the focus is it's cool
to see the behind the scenes of all that
and not just you know the men who are
nice pale face white guys like me but
you know the other people who are there
to who are like doing things that are
extremely important that our history
changing how often do you hear about a
female scientist in any platform ever
it's not something that usually focused
on especially in movies
yes it's rare you just never hear about
female figures in science ever so nice
you've had a change of pace where it's
literally a movie focusing on a female
scientist no matter their race doesn't
matter their gender just left somebody
be brilliant and run brilliant right you
got the fact she's got the the
brainpower just let her go to work you
know who cares I also enjoy the fact
that this is it like a wholesome family
move it you can take kids to where you
wouldn't think you'd be able to bring
kids to this but it's very
family-friendly very appropriate for
little kids to be seen something like
this like get your little girls
interested in sciences or young Bulls or
young boys okay
you know what I really like about the
fact that it's a family movie most
critics really enjoyed this film but
some of the detractors are saying that
it's a little too watered down that it's
a little it's not quite as serious as it
should be that it sort of glosses over
some more serious issues I heartily
disagree and here's why
every movie that deals with racial
strife does not have to be rated R it's
extremely important for young people to
see movies like this I was actually
really happy this movie didn't just
throw in the obligatory f-bomb to get
the pg-13 right because a lot of movies
do that because they're afraid that if
it's PG
it won't do well at the box office
because people think it's too kitty or
family-friendly but this movie is really
performing well at the box office it's
already out grossed its budget and it's
important for young people like not
teenagers like four eight nine ten year
olds to see movies like this and they
can't if it's rated R so I like the fact
this movie is more aimed at families and
I don't necessarily think it's waters
down the subject that yeah it makes it a
little theatrical sometime and a little
bit like you know stick it to the man
kind of deal but that's fine like kids
should grow up seeing stuff like this
it's well acted it has a good message
and it's rare to see characters like
this in a movie that are based on real
life it's one of those things you're
sitting there unlocking it and you're
just smiling and laughing the whole time
or you're very into it and you're like
what's going to happen next even though
we know what's gonna happen next we
study history in school like it's one of
interests like you feel connected to
these people and you feel their struggle
you feel if you want to punch somebody
that you serve your characters great
it's like you spend the first 20 minutes
I'm like I really want to hit this
person for being so nasty or having this
look on their face right now I know like
you start to come to care about these
characters so much and it's nice it's a
change of pace we always get such
self-serious movies that have to have a
political agenda and this is just all
about not being into the world and to
stop and all about just the moment that
getting John Glenn into space and
orbiting getting a job done right good I
mean the job no matter what as for
issues with hidden figures it's hard to
pinpoint one because it's a feel-good
movie it's enjoyable you know it's not
like you watch this movie and go that
was bad like that part was bad but I
guess for me I didn't really feel like
the the romance was all that well
fleshed out in fact it was sort of just
a subplot that was there to kind of make
you feel a little good and show what's
going on in her life at that time and
but I'd never really felt all that
attached it was sweet you know when he
comes
around and mashallah Lila is a fantastic
actor when he comes around and he's very
charming good-looking guy it's sweet but
I didn't really feel like it added that
much this story it but the film kind of
wisely quickly goes back to NASA
whenever it gets a little into that for
me I was like okay let's see what's
going on behind the scenes of NASA and
it doesn't focus too much on it that's
really my only thing about the film I
can pinpoint yeah I wish I'd seen more
of her kids and more of her husband and
sure of that because it's actually fun
they're still alive and they're still
married at 56 something years now that
they haven't been together and it's just
kind of like so quickly through the film
that it doesn't pay as much attention to
to her kids her mother and her
husband I could maybe like five four
minutes in the movie of just some more
interval scenes with her family and less
like every time you see her kids you're
at a party yeah it did kind of feel like
they were like we have to have these in
the movie because it's part of her life
but they wanted to just get back to the
more dramatic stuff at NASA so they kind
of showed it like this happens let's
make this good let's act well in these
scenes but let's forget mecha net
so I think that was really my only issue
with the entire film that was probably
my only complaint is that there's maybe
not enough of her kids and her husband
which I guess isn't too big of it from
but it's still one of those things where
it's like and it's a little bit more
would have been good yeah five four
minutes that's all really what it needed
so overall we both really enjoyed hidden
figures I think we're both recommending
it pretty hard alee it's a feel-good
movie it's a good message take your kids
to it if you're older and you have kids
I think it's something that they could
enjoy and also a little bit of a lesson
from I'm going to give hidden figures
and a - I'm going to get hidden figures
and a just a straight-up a I was like oh
okay so just a straight-up a I really
enjoyed it
um but I promise of more connection for
the character than Chris did because
I've done a paper on her and did
research on her no I mean I thought she
was great in the movie I
really enjoyed it and let me check it
out guys thank you so much as always for
watching thank you to my beautiful wife
Sam for joining me in this video I
always enjoy joining you on that note as
always if you like this you can click
right here and get stockman eyes
[Applause]
[Music]